thank you very much indeed to order
members it's now 5 30
and time for our meeting of the council
now good evening members
officers of the council and members of
the present public i welcome to this
meeting of the council
known as the budget council setting the
finances and the first council meeting
of 2021.
now prior to the this meeting all
participants
should have previously checked that they
can be heard
and seen and can see and hear other
members
it is vital that you can be heard and is
preferred the cameras are kept on
throughout the meeting to double check
this and to introduce everyone who is
present
at this remote meeting i would kindly
ask that i confirm your attendance
and your role or job title when i call
your name
we're starting in alphabetical order
i've got council album
yeah uh present chair and uh
councillor for eastcliff ward and
cabinet member for operational services
thank you councillor
good evening chair yes councillor for
central harbor in ramsgate
thank you counselor ashby
thank you chair westbrook ward and
shadow leader
thank you councillor bailey
president chair uh viking ward
councillor
councillor bambridge
councillor bambridge i'll come back
it's okay sorry sorry chairman my the
mute button wasn't working
um president um councillor westgate on c
thank you
thank you very much councillor jill
bayford
sorry chair president um councillor for
bradstow ward
portfolio hold off
you're cutting in and out hello
councillor bayford are you still with us
sorry chest yeah i'll repeat um
councillor for breadstow award
and shadow uh portfolio holder for
housing
thank you very much councillor robbie
bob
council bayford you wouldn't miss this
for worlds he was here a moment ago and
then the sign came up saying he'd left
the meeting so i think he's probably
trying to get back in
i'll come back count the boyd president
chair councillor
going to ask to list his apologies uh
chairman this is councillor piper
not as yet i shall be coming back
because i'm sure he's with us as he
lodged himself previously
i'm back with you chairman now sorry
about that excellent of course you are
councillor
uh bayford uh councillor braidwood
i will be announcing his apologies
apologies from councillor braidwood
councillor campbell
probably apologies as well council
campbell
councillor coleman cook a president
chair
uh burchington north and vice chair of
planning
thank you very much councillor
christensen
uh president chair councillor for east
cliff ward
councillor curry president chair
councillor for cliftonville west
councillor day
council today are you with us councillor
day
i'll come back counselor
dennis present chair
garland walt councillor dexter
president chairman councillor for some
peter's ward
councillor duckworth present chair
cabinet member for estates and economic
developments
dane valley ward thank you councillor
everett
uh president chair councillor for
newington and leader of the council
councillor farence
councillor farence i shall come back
councillor fellows yeah evening chair
archington south thank you
council again uh present chair
councillor for cliftonville east
thank you councillor ghana
president councillor some petersburg
leader of the green group
thank you councillor green
country yes present councillor for
nethercourt
thank you councillor heart i can see you
here chair uh counsellor for danic
villages
thank you councillor hopkinson
uh yeah i'm here chair uh councillor for
the moses wants fury award in ramsgate
thank you councillor huxley
here chair i'm eastcliff councillor in
ramsgate
thank you councillor keane
counselor keen
i shall come back councillor cup
present chair councillor for birch and
south and shadow cabinet member for
operational services
thank you councillor pat moore
here chair counselor moses montefiore
thank you councillor paul moore present
chair
councillor for beacon ward thank you
councillor oven
a present chair member for difficult
councillor parsons good evening chair
councillor for bradsdale
thank you councillor linda piper
present chair councillor for northwood
councillor stuart piper president chair
a councillor for northwood and leader of
the senate independence
thank you councillor potts
counselor pots i shall come back
councillor pugh president chair
councillor for standard villages ward
and shadow deputy leader thank you
councillor ratigan
here chair council for clifton pegwell
counter roth president chair
councillor for beacon ward council
rogers
councillor rogers i shall come back
councillor ropa president chair
councillor for
fanuc villages thank you council roseki
president chair councillor for northwood
uh ward and uh deputy leader of the
senate independence
thank you councillor david saunders
councillor david saunders
here just worry about that the uh mute
button here chair um viking wall
councillor
shadow cabinet member for finance thank
you very much councillor
maeve saunders
i'm sure you're here there you are
i've got you present chairman
fighting rules for stairs and chairman
of joint transportation
thank you thank you very much uh
councillor scobee
present chair cliftonville west
i have apologies from councillor scott
already
councillor shrub here chair and
cliftonville east
thank you councillor tomlinson here
chair good evening
um council for westbrook and the chair
of
planning thank you councillor towning
good evening a councillor for
cliftonville east
thank you councillor whitehead
present chair um councillor for margate
central
deputy leader and cabinet holder for
housing and safe communities that's
right
thank you councillor wing
present chair central harbour round
ramsgate
thank you thank you council right
south birchington ward and vice chairman
of the council
quite so councillor yates
president chair margate central ward and
cabinet member for finance
administration and community wealth
building just as well
you're important tonight now going back
uh
councilman or bayford yes i did have
councillor campbell other apologies
are you with us chairman if i can
it's councillor alvin chairman yes
apologist for
councillor campbell uh he's in hospital
chairman thank you
well i'm sure we're all very sorry to
hear that um indeed
uh counselor day coming back to you are
you there councillor day
i think we'll have to mount councillor
day down as
absent uh councillor
green councillor green are you with us
now
um yes chair presents great and you are
witch ward uh nether court and southward
wars
excellent thank you very much councillor
keane coming back to you are you with us
now
a chair councillor keane sends her
apologies
and can i also point out that councillor
gregory
is in attendance as well right
i shall check that yes i've got
a dentist in attendance actually uh
thank you
councillor potts are you with us now
um i'll give uh councillor potts
apologies chair
right okay i have those now
uh councillor rogers president
councillor for cliffsend and peggle
excellent
right i think i've got a record
everybody present
absent and attendances we also have an
attendance tonight the chief executive
miss homer
the deputy chief executive mr willis the
director of operational services
mr waite the director of law and
democracy ms culligan
and the committee services manager mr
hughes
now if you have technical difficulties
during the meeting
then please contact one of the
democratic service officers
on call who will attempt to assist you i
would ask participants when you are not
speaking please
mute your microphones this minimizes
background noise and will help
everyone in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate
on the chat to the right side of the
screen
i will then make a note and go back to
you once the person speaking has
finished
i should just put mine on now to make
certain i've got you up that's
it now then um please note this meeting
is being
live streamed for members of the public
except for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered
following the exclusion of present
public from the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet uh with everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst
meeting is in progress do not turn your
phone off
as it will make it harder for any deputy
services
to contact you should they need to
please also refrain from checking
emails or conducting other business and
ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
now agenda item one i've had apologies
as previously noted uh
i don't think i need to make a dose of
any other apologies
uh agenda item two minutes of the
meeting
held on the 10th of december 2020. i
move the minutes of the meeting of the
council held on the 10th of december
2020 be approved as a correct record
uh vice chair would you please second
i'll second that mr chairman
now if anyone objects the minutes i will
then take them as agreed
thank you now agenda item three
announcements i have not been involved
with any announcements
um one announcement or observation of my
own however
all of us i'm sure saw the disappointing
hanbury parish council meeting
i just like to say that throughout my
tenure as chairman i believe
our council meetings have been very well
served by members
and i can say i felt proud to have been
chairman
throughout i think you've all
represented your wards admirably
we need to carry the public esteem and i
think we have done so here admirably
so thank you very much moving on to
agenda item four
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest this evening
i'm not getting any feedback at all
so no one's making any so straight into
agenda item
five the treasury management strategy
for 2021 to 2022.
um i call upon council yates
councillor yates are you with us thank
you chair
um this report and annexes the cabinet
this report and annexes the cabinet
approved on the 14th of january as well
as governance and audit on the 25th of
november 2020
includes the proposed treasury
management strategy statement the
minimum
revenue provision policy statement the
annual investment strategy
capital strategy and non-treasury
investment report
for 21 to 22. i moved the
recommendations
thank you very much councillor yes do
you have a secondary
second that chair counts counselor album
thank you very much indeed uh council
saunders
i believe you'd like a word at this
point
are you there councilman saunders
are you having trouble with your mute
again i am indeed that's
most unusual for me isn't it um yes
um we'd just like to recall our
appreciation to the section 151 officer
the director of finance and indeed the
whole of the finance team
who have contributed to the preparation
of the treasury management strategy
in what has been challenging
circumstances and i think we all
understand that
especially with the added burden of
administering the various grants
associated
with the ongoing covid pandemic so on
behalf of the conservative group
thank you thank you very well said
councillor saunders thank you very much
indeed now the recommendation
is the council approves this report and
annexes
so unless anyone objects the proposal i
will take this as agreed
i'm not seeing any objections and so
therefore i think we can take that as
agreed therefore moving straight on to
agenda item
6 the 2021-2022 budget
this item presents the 2021-2022 budget
for the council
and the 2021-2025 capital program
now the recommendations will be that the
council approves
one the general fund revenue budget
estimates
2021 to 2022 as approved assuming a 4.99
pound increase the band d
equivalent for council tax number two
the hra the household revenue account
budget estimate for 20 21 22 approved
number three the general fund and
housing revenue account cattle
programmes
for 2021 25 are approved number four the
flexible use of capital receipt strategy
for 2021
2022 is approved and number five that
section one five one offers a securing
statement
is no ticked can i turn to councillor
yates
thank you chair this budget is being
presented during an extraordinary time
for local council
this time last year we had no idea how
much cover 19 would affect our lives
since then this council has supported
vulnerable residents with food parcels
and welfare checks
paid over 50 million pounds of grants to
struggling businesses
supported the nhs with coca test centers
and vaccination centers
and continue to deliver frontline
services
firstly i would like to say a big thank
you to all our council staff
the nhs to our community groups
frontline workers
and a thank you to each of our
councillors for the work you have done
to support the community in this
difficult time
and i believe to speak for everyone here
when i say that our thoughts are with
those who have lost friends and loved
ones
this 17 million pound general fund
budget and 15 million pound hra budget
covers the period april 2021
to march 2022 and it's worth saying here
that for every pound a resident pays in
council tax only 12 pence of it
is in relation to the finance district
council given the large cuts to local
government that the conservative
government have imposed upon us over the
last decade
we are having to increase council tax by
2 this represents an
average annual increase in council tax
of 4 pounds 99 to a band d
household but this is not enough to fund
local government
and it makes me angry to say that we are
once again having to make cuts within
founder district council
we as the labour administration have
worked hard to challenge the assumptions
behind the cuts
and reduce the impact on frontline
services and redundancies
we are proud to have found the money to
allow at least the one percent pay award
for our staff
who have worked tirelessly over the last
year doing their jobs in exceptional
circumstances
local government has shown during the
last year and we are once again being
let down by a central government
before asking for support for the budget
which has already been shown to councils
extensive briefings thanks to our
finance officers
i would like to take a moment to pause
and run through some of the council's
achievements over the last years
and use the council's 2019-2023
corporate statement as our guide
this will provide our background to what
we hope to build on within this year's
budget
on growth we have been awarded 2.7
million pounds to ramsgate's future high
street fund we have submitted a 29
million pound bid for margate town deal
board
we have supported the development of a
new train station planet athanic parkway
providing access to london in an hour
they'll be powered by electric trains
and they'll bring new jobs and
investment we have set up a successful
business engagement facebook page called
fanuc business support
this allows us to speak directly to our
local businesses and together with our
hard-working finance and grant teams has
already mentioned
we've been able to update individuals on
their grants during this very
challenging time for business
we have signed up to community wealth
building the basis of which is to
encourage large organizations in planet
to spend their money locally where
possible
within this we've signed up to a
community wealthfund alliance that could
bring up
10 million pounds to our five two to
five of our most left behind wards
and this is not unique to thana kent
county council has a scheme called the
kent pound
and we're trying to use this concept of
community wealth building
to when it when it comes to bringing
east kent housing in the house as well
tourism continues to be a priority for
the district and we've been supporting
businesses
through this extremely challenging year
and promoting the destination through
our tourism and comms teams
research shows that before covered
planets than its visitor economy was
valued at 352 million pounds
after welcoming 4.6 million visitors in
2019
the number of tourism jobs across the
district showed a nine percent increase
between 2017 and 2019
this is and this equates to 864 jobs
which accounts for 20 percent of planets
total employment last year
we've also sold parts of dreamland and
we're using the receipt to pay off debt
relating to dreamland which saves on
borrowing costs
and we've taken back control of margate
harbor on from the end of february this
year bringing back more money into the
council
on environments and the climate have
hired an education
enforcement officer who is actively
engaging with residents on waste and
recycling
to try and reduce the amount of waste
fire tipping litter and dog fouling we
produce
they have actively engaged with local
schools and will be focusing on coastal
issues with litter over this summer
season
we have hired a new climate change
officer who is coordinating and leading
on the authority's response to climate
emergency
they'll be developing the council's
action plan further alongside new
strategies for the council in relation
to trees and biodiversity
examples of some of the actions
including cheaper greener energy deal
for the council's gas and electricity
and applying for external funding to
decarbonize the council-owned
kent innovation center we have hired a
home energy officer
who is helping residents with low
incomes to get support for home energy
heating and insulation
this resulted in hundreds of residents
referred to get support to install
new cavity wall insulation loft
insulation and technology for hot water
and heating
on top of this we have access to wide a
wide a range of new support schemes for
families who have problems with fuel
bills and struggle to keep the home warm
for more information please contact the
council's energy advice service
we are in the process of hiring five new
full-term
full-time environmental operatives who
will focus on open spaces and street
cleansing
we have increased the number of
recycling bins in planet we're in the
process of trialing recycling bins at
rovecore and kennedy core in ramsgate
and we plan to expand the scheme
we hired portaloos for some of our
busiest beaches where visitor numbers
were extremely high
we have trialled a successful
pedestrianization scheme in margate to
allow pedestrians to walk more freely
through our town
and we have closed off parking outside
ramsgate's popular seafront restaurants
and pubs
giving their businesses more space in
the limited code restricted summer we
had
we have introduced a discount to the
license fee for hybrid and electric
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicles
and introduced electric taxi charging
points in birchington and margay
and we have moved electronic meetings we
have moved to electronic meetings thanks
to our
excellent hard work from our committee
services manager in the digital team
and not only has this been a success as
tonight proves it also reduces the
associated carbon emissions of having
face-to-face meetings
although i must admit to missing the
in-person face-to-face meetings
on communities we have taken control of
east kent housing
which brings 3 400 council high homes
under tdc control
i'll last check there are no
non-compliant properties in relation to
gas safety checks
and we are on target to confirm that we
are fully compliant by march and this
year
to support residents going forward we've
also hired a new engagement officer
so residents can more easily discuss
issue issues with the council
we are undertaking long overdue works on
our tower blocks and properties
ensuring that residents are safe and
well protected including work on fire
safety
block security lifts and cttb we've
supported community groups
such as our kitchen food club by finding
suitable premises
which has allowed the organizing
organization to attract national funding
their work has received national
recognition when prime minister boris
johnson awarded them a point of light
award we are building more social
housing
with foie house and margate our first
in-house temporary accommodation
currently under construction
these actions look to address 1713
people
currently on the housing waiting list we
have run our first 24-hour winter
shelter
working alongside the award-winning rise
team the salvation army and partner
organizations and will continue to look
for ways to access and support our most
vulnerable rough sleepers
since the beginning of a pandemic we've
organized demand our covered support
line
still answering over 45 calls per week
and tdc's staff
continued i've contacted over 8
200 residents known to be clinically
extremely vulnerable
directly just to ensure that they have
the support they need
and we have worked to ensure that the 20
pound increase to universal credit
that has affected tens of thousands of
our residents is not applicable to their
council tax and housing benefit payments
so the 20 pound increase has really
meant a 20 pound increase
okay so that was quick quick fire but
that's the update on the corporate
statement and i think we will agree
that we are delivering concrete
achievements looking ahead
the budget for next year 2022 to 2023
is looking even more difficult and
thanks to the lack of funding from this
conservative government we'll most
likely need to make additional savings
or create new revenue on top of those
made this year
it will be necessary to identify savings
and revenue opportunities both within
the mtfs
and other options to ensure the
successful running of this council
to conclude as i've highlighted tonight
with concrete examples
we believe that this council is
achieving what we all set out to achieve
in our four-year plan
we are presenting a balanced budget that
looks to support residents and
businesses during this terrible pandemic
and we will continue to work
hand-in-hand with the residents of
thanet
and move the council approves the budget
thank you very much need counsellor
yates um is there a seconder
yeah i'm second in that chairman
councillor alban councillor album
uh i have allowed you a little longer
councillor yates and therefore
anybody else speaking um i shall
likewise
indulge with a little longer as well
just to note everyone councillor day has
joined the meeting
and so therefore is present uh i should
now call on councillor
david saunders um to reply to councillor
yates
councillor saunders are you there thank
you chairman yes
and i've managed to unmute um so
here we go very short and sweet can i
just say that in normal circumstances
as an opposition party with the largest
representation within this authority
you would expect us to be making
critical comment at this point
however we are not in normal
circumstances
and although there are elements of
concern within the budget that's before
us this evening
we appreciate the challenges presented
to the service directors particularly
in achieving the necessary savings and
also the financial team in preparing
a balanced budget whilst protecting
essential services
we will therefore be supporting the
recommendations
but that said we will be monitoring
progress throughout the forthcoming
financial year
and scrutinizing as necessary once we
get the quarterly figures coming through
that's all i need to say no political
sizing on my part thank you
yes thank you very much any counselor
saunders and that was
noted you have strayed away from any
political comment
i have counselor ghana who would like to
speak counselor ghana
thank you thank you very much um well of
course
we we also recognize that we find
ourselves in
extraordinary times and that number of
factors
including both the pandemic and the
drastic cuts to funding from central
government
mean that the council faces an overspend
of 850
000 to deal with and we welcome the fact
that there will be minimal impact
on the delivery of frontline public
services for residents
we'd also like to recognise and thank
all staff
who've worked so hard this year to help
so many of our residents get through the
pandemic
and maintain delivery of essential
services
we do however have an issue with the
fact
that the budget being presented to us
this evening doesn't give enough
consideration
to the climate emergency that we as a
council
unanimously voted through 18 months ago
which means that we as a group will be
abstaining from the vote this evening
tackling the climate emergency should
not be a nice to have
it should be considered in everything we
do and every plan we spend
as an example one area we know that
needs extra funding
is planning enforcement we're already
proposing policy
changes to our local plan through the
climate change working group
and the local plan review to make sure
that all of the many new developments
coming down the line
comply with tougher climate emergency
biodiversity conditions
we need to make sure that we build out
our enforcement function
to equip them to make sure the new local
plan policies are actually implemented
we should be fined finding funding for
that
in a way that would be self-sustaining
going forward and other climate
emergency related schemes
before finding funding for other
projects like the installation of
jet ski births or some of the other
six-figure projects in
in the pool if we do not prioritise
addressing the issues raised
by the climate emergency as a matter of
urgency an increasingly aware community
especially the young who are concerned
about climate change
will quite rightly question our
priorities we have to be seen to be
committing to the changes required in
planning
in waste management in pollution
management through control of traffic
and in support of clean energies and
also to be harnessing the skills
knowledge and commitment in the local
community to work with us to do these
things
if we wait any longer it will be too
late
thank you thank you councillor ghana
i have councillor whitehead
thank you very much chair uh just in
response to
councillor ghana i'd like to reassure
him that the climate emergency
notwithstanding the pandemic is
obviously
at the center of an awful lot of the
changes that have been made
across departments and so
as you yourself said this isn't a
singular issue this is something that
affects
everything it affects every area and
so although you may not find things
under particular banners
if you think of in of housing in
particular we now have developments with
solar panels with underfloor heating
with extra insulation um with
measures to try and ensure that both
residents have as an easy time as
possible in terms of bills
and also to ensure that our housing is
as energy efficient
as possible so that we can move to our
zero carbon target
um in terms of
referencing cancer yates's earliest
speech
obviously the work of the energy officer
also contributes towards that
so what we're seeing really here is a
crossover
what we're trying to do is work on this
issue across all departments
and within all policies and so although
you may not see things under particular
banners or particular
labels rest assured work is happening
within each department and within each
cabinet
role in order to make sure that those
needs are prioritized
i'd also like to add a personal thanks
to
everybody who has worked throughout this
pandemic
i know how hard so many of the officers
have worked i know how hard so many of
our workers have worked
um and i would also like to thank every
single counselor who
has done an outstanding job in
an absolutely incredibly difficult time
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
i think that's very well said
and thank you for answering councillor
ghana so well
uh call upon the leader councillor
everett
thank you chair yeah um i don't intend
to say very much i mean this is this is
councillor yates um
evening really um i would like to thank
all our officers really across the
council for all the hard work that's
gone into this budget process
particularly the finance officers but
not just the the finance officers
because
the budget building process does involve
difficult choices
it does involve a lot of careful thought
and it has been a um it has been i think
a very
good process and i'm i'm really
reassured by the involvement of members
as in previous years
members have all had the opportunity to
engage with the finance team throughout
the process
um the budget has been to um cabinet and
scrutiny
scrutiny didn't recommend any changes
but obviously had some comments to make
and i absolutely respect that we bring
it to council as one document with lots
of different things in it
and it's constructive that we get on and
pass it i just wanted to say
uh in relation to um councillor ghana's
comments about jet skis
um clearly we would only introduce these
jet ski births at the harbour
because we expect the council to make
money out of them that can be spent on
council services
um so i don't quite understand the
argument that it's not a financial
priority
and certainly if there are other things
that which will generate more money
for the council to provide services then
we'd be hap we're always happy to look
at those
um but it's not a choice between jet
skis and and other things which
benefit the residents there will be a
benefit to residents
personally i'm not an enthusiast for jet
skis but i think that um
if we are going to have them then they
have to be properly managed and the
harbour
is a good place from which they can be
managed where we have staff
and where there can be proper oversight
so um with that caveat you know
i thank the other members for their
comments and i hope everyone will vote
for the budget
thank you thank you council over it i
just noticed
hard to imagine you on a jet ski um
now any other comments do i have any
other comments from members
no one else wishes to speak so far as i
can see
i need to advise that in accordance with
council procedure rule 17.6
i will call for a recorded vote on the
motion
or any amendment and substantive motions
so i therefore instruct the deputy
monitoring officer
to conduct the recorded vote um
are you there um
yes chair thanks very much hello members
so i'll read everybody's name
out in alphabetical order so um
counselor album
counselor ira four
councillor ashby four
councillor bailey for
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford for
councillor robert bayford four
councillor boyd
councillor coleman cook four
councillor crittenden for
councillor curry four
councillor day four
four councillor dennis
four councillor dexter
for councillor duckworth
for councillor everett
uh councillor farence
i'm sorry is councillor farrell's here i
don't believe my mother is a turkey
before okay thank you um councillor
fellows
four councillor game
four councillor ghana
abstain
councillor green
[Applause]
four councillor gregory
four councillor heart
four council hopkinson
councillor hopkinson sorry
thank you councillor huxley fourth
councillor cup for
councillor patmore
four councillor paul moore
four councillor ovindon
councillor linda piper four
councillor stuart piper
thank you councillor ratigan for
councillor for
councillor rogers for
councillor ropa abstain
thank you councillor rozeki
four councillor david saunders
four councillor maeve saunders
four
[Music]
tomlinson four
councillor towning or
councillor whitehead four
councillor wing abstain
councillor right four
and councillor yates four
thank you very much let me just do a bit
of counting up
just to be absolutely sure
just bear with me a moment
so i make that 45 4 and 3 abstentions
thank you very much
well i think that went very smoothly
council so
thank you very much let's move on to
agenda item
seven uh and this is the member
allowances scheme
21 20 21
i move the recommendations are set out
in the report be adopted
with the vice chairman please second
guess thank you very much indeed
now unless anyone objects the proposal i
take it as agreed
thank you gender item eight
changes to committees panels and boards
for 20 20 21 proportionality
i move the recommendation as detailed at
paragraph 3.6.1 of the report be
approved
with the vice chairman please second i
ch second that mr chairman
and the as unless anyone objects the
proposal i'll take it as agreed
thank you now on to nomination of
members to serve on committees
uh group leaders may take this
opportunity to advise of any changes to
the nomination
the committees panels and boards for the
remainder of twenty twenty
twenty one councillor everett do you
wish to advise of any nomination changes
uh i do chair um and these are all to
replace councillor campbell who as we
know is in
sadly in ill health on the general
purposes committee councillor alban
on the overview and scrutiny committee
councillor curry
and on the standards committee
councillor scobee
i don't have a replacement as a reserve
on the planning committee
at this meeting thanks thank you that's
no to catholic era
catholic ashby do you wish to advise any
nomination changes
not this evening thank you chair uh you
perhaps
may do into your course uh counselor
reverend stuart piper do you wish to
advise any nomination changes
thank you mr german um i've got one
uh seat to move and that would be
councillor rozeki
moving to planning to replace
uh former councillor gary taylor
and if you don't mind mr chairman if i
could just take 30 seconds to say
not only from our political group's
point of view but i'm sure on behalf of
the council
a message of thanks to can't former
councillor
taylor he has been a very high profile
counsellor a very busy counsellor
he's made the local media on a number of
occasions because of the amount of work
that he does and all of this
particularly in the last 12 months
um at a time when his
work life the post office and deliveries
has been
so busy uh he really has been i think
a beacon of light to show how counseling
could be done and maybe some would say
should be done but thank you for letting
me
give a message of thanks to gary taylor
for his service and also remembering he
was vice chairman of the council
for a time and performed that role very
very well indeed
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor piper and i'm happy to
endorse that i too have noted councillor
taylor's um
uh appearances in the local media
thank you very much uh councillor garner
do you wish to advise of any nomination
changes
no nomination changes for me although i
will uh
um echo council of piper's comments
about councillor taylor
i know how busy he's been and i know
he's he's been very helpful to me on
occasion
um when i started out as a counsellor so
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
ghana before i close the meeting i would
just like to finish off by saying that
i'm sure
all of us here this evening wish very
best wishes
to councillor campbell currently in
hospital's moment
and we all hope the best very best for
him
that concludes the business of meeting
of this council this evening
thank you very much for your attendance
and thank you very much for a smooth
meeting this evening good night thank
you